twelve-year-old Hank and his mother Lily
have made the discovery that Walter was
once famous in this scene Walter has a
discussion with Hank his young friend
about Walter's former life and thoughts
on fame and fortune exterior Lilly's
trailered day Walter knocks on the door
the lock clicks Hank emerges on the
other side come on marina she's at the
court seeing the judge I can't keep the
door open supposed to keep his shut-in
locked
Hank motions for all to come in Hank
looks down to see Henrietta the dog
following behind him hi Henrietta Hank
bends down and gives her a pet and a hug
interior Lilly's trailer continuous
Walter steps inside he sees that Hank
holds tightly on to a small red canister
as he rises from his embrace lock works
real good sure I'm allowed Henrietta I
don't know but what the hell
Hank closes and locks the door he sets
the canister down what you got there
bear spray just in case it costs mama
too much to keep this place nice and
food on the table well he comes acts up
all her hard work ends up being for
nothing mm-hmm come back hey shakes his
head fine
Hank shakes his head again mm-hmm sorry
you got hurt I'm not hurt I gotta be
heading out for a few days if you could
tell your mama mighty appreciate it
Haigh sets out to glasses pours kool-aid
punch sure where you been all this time
where's all your money Walter saddles up
to the counter as if he were in a bar in
Hanko bartender Hank pushes a glass
toward him Walter takes a sip don't got
any where is it
ex-wife has it now oh I've been mad as
hell deserve why Hank pour some water in
a bowl for Henrietta sets it down
something was gripping ahold of me
around your neck no take your paw you
mean my daddy yeah let's say something
gripped him ha something what well
something you don't happen can't see but
behave the way he does I don't know
about that or she don't you don't got it
but it's clear to him as you being able
to play the guitar and it's hard for him
to explain to you it's hard for him to
show you he's different inside comes out
bad hurts everyone that happened to you
Walter nods followed by a long slow sip
of kool-aid
I hope mama comes home soon I'm starved
why don't you make the dinner huh like
what I don't know just don't go burning
the house down I'll do it I'll do it
good idea Walter unlocks the door to
leave Henrietta stays seated I think
she's better about it you being famous
and all Dickey had a talk with her about
life and all sorts of stuff o'clock the
door Walter opens the door one thing
more said do you miss being a famous
country singer I am a country singer not
famous Wow I wasn't living right back
then are you now
you know Geronimo the Indians again
uh-huh he was warmed by the Sun rocked
by the winds and sheltered by the trees
he could go everywhere with a good
feeling what the hell is that got to do
with being famous I got it out come on
girl Henrietta pauses but then follows
Walter out Walter closes the door but
before he can one more thing or sad
I think Henrietta wants to stay that may
be the case but I won't need her on this
trip
Walter begins to close the door hey
you're kidding right
you got you got cool a stash on your
face and your tongue is red
you